the Doppler effect in Sheldon's words
it's the apparent change in the
frequency of a wave caused by relative
motion between the source of the wave
when the observer
the Doppler effect is perhaps best
explained visually so here's a thing
that is emitting waves it could be a
fire truck emitting sound it could be a
star emitting light it could be a dot
creating ripples on a pond those are all
waves and they all look something like
this we see the Doppler effect happening
when the thing that is emitting waves
moves in the direction it's moving the
wave fronts bunch up and behind it they
spread out if our object is moving
towards a stationary observer these
bunched up waves are observed at a high
frequency and if the object is moving
away from a stationary observer the
waves are observed at a lower frequency
so that is the Doppler effect the
apparent change in the frequency of a
wave caused by relative motion between
the source of the wave and the observer
it makes sense but it gets interesting
when you consider some of those
applications so let's say you are
standing in the middle of the road
that's that's you and a car drives past
you very fast as it does so it honks its
horn because you're standing in the
middle of the road the home to you might
sound something like this so it starts
at a high pitch and moves to a lower
pitch even though from the drivers
perspective the horn is playing the same
pitch the entire time so what's going on
as the vehicles coming towards you the
sound waves that it's a meeting bunch up
and so I delivered to you at a frequency
which you interpret as a higher pitch
because the frequency of sound waves is
pitch and then when the vehicle passes
you and is moving away from you the
sound waves spread out and so you hear
them at a lower frequency a lower pitch
so that's how the Doppler effect works
with sound
it also affects another kind of wave
light so let's say you look at your
observatory and you see a star just like
the cars sound waves if the star is
moving towards you even it's a little
bit the light waves that it emits will
be bunched up meaning that you see the
light at a higher frequency than it
actually is
frequency and sound is pitch so what
does it mean for light well if we look
at our handy pocket electromagnetic
spectrum chart we'll see that a small
change in frequency for visible light
will change its color higher frequency
light waves means bluer light and low
frequency light waves major red or light
this is called redshift and it may
possibly be among the weirdest and
coolest things of all time stars or
anything that you can see change color
depending on their relative motion to
you of course you can't see this my new
difference with your eyes but
astronomers with the right equipment can
use this effect to tell whether stars
are moving away from or towards Earth as
it turns out almost everything we can
see in the universe is moving away from
us very quickly which is both an
important piece of evidence the Big Bang
and an indication that the earth might
get very lonely in the distant distant
future thanks for watching this video
let me know if you got something out of
it bye